je m'appelle Thomas je suis au rsa
depuis plus de 6 mois grâce au CNN j'ai
décroché un contrat de travail en
métropole au SMIC j'ai ensuite signé
avec mon conseiller d'insertion un
contrat r+, la location d'insertion et
de retour à l'emploi pendant les deux
premiers mois le cnrme finance mon
billet d'avion et mes premiers frais
d'installation mais pas les autres
dépenses comme les frais de transport et
d'aménagement avec mon contrat r+, je
vais toucher 560 euros par mois pendant
trois mois et ainsi faire face à ses
besoins et voir mon avenir plus
sereinement r+, l'activité en toute
sécurité plus d'informations sur
www.département974.fr